a girl with an open
Snapple a boy who's looking down all the
faces and the
memories that we have from right
now raise a glass for everyone that will
come through these hes but in the Glass
isn't alcohol it's something more
profound and the Halls are home at all
of course they're trees and lakes and
birds we all F to find the place we can
belong we all F to find a place we can
call
home can't visit
[Music]
home but is it kind of
of it is I think it
of is
home but is it kind of I think it kind
of
is where every kid picked life and gy
finally makes the team where Square
packs find their hes and outcasts find
their
it's a Melting Pot for belting girls and
boys in tiny shorts come to find Forever
friendship just for hours from New
York to
find we can
be
to pleas we can
call the place we can C
[Music]
down
what is it kind of kind of it is I think
it kind of
[Music]
[Applause]
is Camp taught me that my words are
powerful at Camp I learned that you
don't have to be pretty to be talented
it's just a bonus without Camp I would
have never known I could sing a high F
above middle sea at Camp I learned to
live in my truth as a heterosexual
[Music]
[Applause]
man
all
easy my
[Music]
think I don't want to grow up stop
watching
me stoping
me
my
[Music]
joh Camp isn't home oh what a song these
kids are so
[Music]
talented